So, let's ask ourselves this question.
When control transfers to the ShellCode,
what privileges are going to be
used when this code is executed?
We know the code is attacker code.
The attacker actually created the code,
wasted memory,
transferred control of this program that
we were running before to the ShellCode,
and remember the program was
running on behalf of some users.
So it's a service, it may be running on
behalf of rule or depending on what sort
of rule is this or credentials we
have some role or whatever it is.
It could a system process for example.
So, the program was running
with certain privileges.
This program is now going and
executing these instructions
that make up the ShellCode.
So whose privileges are we going to
be using when the shell code or
the instructions that make
up a ShellCode get executed?
These privileges are going to be
the privileges of the host program,
the program that gets exploited was
running with certain privileges.
This attacker code now has the same
privileges that the host program or
the target program that
could exploit it had.
So if this happened to be
system service as I said,
is running with root privileges.
Essentially, you have
keys to the kingdom.
You can access arbitrary resources,
so the attacker used
a vulnerable program used above for
all the idea that we talked about,
transfer the control to its own code,
that was the ShellCode, and
the ShellCode let's it launch to command
shell, and the command shell now
can start whatever program it wants
to and that program would run on
behalf of the host programs owner or
group privileges whatever that it had.
So the attacker has come in and
become you, either the system or
a particular user who is running
this vulnerable program.
So, this is how the attacker
is able to execute
arbitrary code with a legitimate
user's credentials or privileges.
Legitimate user's privileges
are available to this
arbitrary code that is being
executed on behalf of the attacker.
That's the best case scenario from
the attacker's point of view.
It's the worst case scenario from our
point of view because somebody is
executing code we have no
knowledge of with our privileges.
And they were able to get into the
system because there was a vulnerability
that got successfully exploited and
as a result
the attacker has ability to do
everything that he or she wants to do.